-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here,
and I appreciate it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, today is Friday the 13th.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
This morning -- This morning,
I thought a black cat
jumped in front of me,
but thank God it was just a rat.
[ Laughter ]
I go -- oof!
All right, now let's get to
20 jokes about Taylor Swift.
All right.
Last night --
[ Scattered cheers, laughter ]
That's all we've been
talking about it all week.
Last night, for the third time
this season,
Taylor Swift
was cheering on Travis Kelce
at the Kansas City Chiefs game.
[ Cheers ]
Yep, yep.
The NFL has the biggest pop star
in the world at its games,
while Major League Baseball's
like,
"We have...live organ music."
[ Laughter ]
♪ Dan dan dan dan,
dan dan dan dan ♪
dan dan ♪
Then it goes...
♪ Da da da... ♪
Doesn't it?
[ Musical flourish ]
No, all right.
Not everyone can do it.
It's a hard --
-Almost.
-Not everyone can do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, he doesn't do it
for a living.
-That's all right.
That's all right.
It's very hard.
Very hard.
Say what you want
about this relationship,
but flying to Kansas City on
a Thursday night, that's love.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. That's love.
Taylor watched the game
with Travis's mom and dad.
That's a fun date, huh?
"You want to spend four hours
with my parents
while I play with my friends?"
"All right.
Not really, not really."
Meanwhile, before the game,
announcer Al Michaels promised
that they wouldn't go overboard
with their coverage
of Taylor Swift.
Let's see how they did.
-In case you are wondering,
Taylor Swift is here.
-Of course, his number-one fan,
Taylor Swift,
is here in Arrowhead
to cheer him on.
-Looking on is his good buddy
and girlfriend, Taylor Swift.
Word just came down to me
that Taylor Swift has written
a couple of songs
for us tonight.
Well, everything in moderation,
but here's another shot
of Taylor Swift.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, honestly,
compared to the last two games,
mission accomplished.
I mean, well done.
They barely -- they cut --
The final score was Chiefs 19,
Broncos 8,
cutaways to Taylor 572.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the three big movies
this weekend are
"Taylor Swift: The Eras Tour,"
the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's gonna be giant.
"The Exorcist."
-Ooh!
-And "Saw."
-Oh.
-Yeah, and since
it's Friday the 13th,
we thought we'd combine
them all together,
so please enjoy.
♪♪
-♪'Cause baby's got bad blood ♪
♪ You know it used to be
bad love ♪
♪ So take a look at
what you've done ♪
♪ 'Cause, baby, now we got
bad blood ♪
Hey.
-[ Roars ]
-Unh!
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Happy Friday --
[ Laughs ]
Happy Friday the 13th.
Well, some political news.
After failing to gain
enough support from Republicans,
Congressman Steve Scalise
has dropped out of the race
for House speaker.
Yeah, if we're using Republicans
to measure time,
a Scalise is even shorter
than a Scaramucci.
[ Laughter ]
"I just came in
for a quick Scalise.
It wasn't a full Scaramucci.
It was..."
[ Laughter ]
The House is a mess,
McCarthy got voted out,
Scalise couldn't
get enough votes,
and the interim speaker
slams the gavel
like he's playing
Whac-A-Mole.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The search
for a new speaker
has been pretty chaotic.
First, it was Kevin McCarthy,
then it was Steve Scalise,
and now it doesn't seem
like anyone else
can get enough votes.
But tonight, the House
finally picked a new nominee,
and he's here now,
via satellite, from D.C.
Please welcome the new pick
for speaker of the House,
Tim Barrett.
Tim, thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks for having me, Jimmy.
I'm very excited
to represent my party
and my country
in this new role,
and I'm ready to hit
the ground running.
-Now, Tim, what would you say
your biggest goals
are as you take over
the office of speaker?
-Great question. Jimmy.
I think that, above all,
we need to come together --
-Yeah, yeah, I'm sorry.
Hang on. I'm sorry.
What's going on?
What happened to Tim?
-Oh, he dropped out.
-Just --
Just now he dropped out?
-That's right.
I'm the new nominee,
and I couldn't be more excited
to get started.
-Yeah, yeah, okay.
But I'm sorry, but who are you?
-My name is Bill Doyle.
-Okay, Bill,
I'm a little thrown off,
but I guess I'll ask you
the same thing.
What are your biggest goals
as speaker?
-Party unity, Jimmy.
That's where it all starts.
-Yeah. I'm sorry. Wait.
Who are you?
-I'm Jordan Roth,
the new nominee
for speaker of the House.
-You're the new
speaker nominee?
-That's right, Jimmy.
Hank Remington.
Nice to meet you.
-I'm sorry. Wait.
Another nominee for speaker?
That's, like the fourth one
in a minute.
How is this even happening?
-I know. It's a little cuckoo
around here, L-O-L.
-Wait. I'm sorry.
Tim?
You're here again?
You're back in the running?
-No, I just forgot
my car keys.
-Oh, well, that's enough.
Will someone just tell me who
the new speaker of the House is?
-My name is Lewis.
[ Laughter ]
The new speaker is Lewis,
the target Halloween decoration?
I am not the speaker.
My name is Lewis.
-Okay, good. You know,
I think we're done here.
Give it up for the new
speaker of the House, Lewis.
[ Applause ]
Listen to this --
apparently, Netflix plans
to open their own stores
where customers can play games,
shop, and eat.
Yeah, they'll even have servers
going up to tables going,
"Are you still eating?
3, 2, 1..."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, since it's Netflix,
people are like,
"We like to skip the appetizers,
go right to the main course."
[ Laughter ]
The only rule at
the Netflix restaurant is,
you can't share your food.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Hey, I read that Jeff Bezos
just bought
his Florida neighbor's mansion
for $79 million.
Jeff Bezos is the only person
who sees an $80 million mansion
and goes, "Closet?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man
pleading guilty to stealing
the "Wizard of Oz" ruby slippers
from a museum in Minnesota.
Yeah. Or as he tells
his cellmate, "Murder.
I'm in for murder."
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.
Kelly Clarkson
is here to talk and perform
a song off her new album!
[ Cheers and applause ]
New York Rangers legend
Henrik Lundqvist is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go write some
thank-you notes.
Come on, everybody.
-♪ Riggity rock
is my favorite cartoon ♪
♪ Aftermath is a honeymoon ♪
♪ Ay, yo, me, oh, my ♪
♪ Just gag me with a spoon ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, everybody, welcome!
I went to go see
a "Gutenberg!" last night.
-Ooh! How was it?
-This is --
This is my actual one.
See, it's all -- it's all --
I thought I'd get a nice,
new crisp one,
but this is the one I had.
Was moving around.
I didn't put it in my pocket.
-It's got
the opening night sticker.
-When you go to opening night,
you get the sticker.
So that's what I wanted
to show off. Yeah.
You got that special sticker.
It was unbelievable.
They were hilarious.
It was great.
Was that the James Earl Jones
Theatre here in Broadway?
I haven't been to a Broadway
play in a little bit,
so, I mean, the show
has been off for five months,
so I haven't really been around,
but it was so great.
I loved everyone
that put on this --
the play and everyone
that works here around.
I just miss Broadway.
I love seeing the red carpet.
I saw the Broadway.com guy.
I love that guy. He's fantastic.
I saw him.
I was -- It was --
I saw Anna Wintour.
-Ooh.
-Sat in front of Anna.
-Ooh!
-No big deal.
It's not a big deal, right?
Who cares?
No one -- No one's asking.
-Did you --
Who did you sit in front of?
-Oh, Anna?
-Anna who?
-Oh, Anna Wintour.
You ever heard of "Vogue"?
-Oh, my gosh.
-She was behind me
the whole time.
-Really?
-No, not a big deal.
So I guess I got good seats.
[ Laughter ]
It was
the James Earl Jones Theatre.
And if you're a fan
of James Earl Jones
or even "Star Wars"
at the beginning,
they have a funny joke
that's really good,
but you just have to
listen to it. It's very --
But it's all --
There's all jokes spread out.
It's crazy, by the way.
The play is nuts.
It's absolutely -- it's about
two guys are pitching a play,
and they know nothing
about Gutenberg
and the printing press,
and it's -- it's bizarre.
[ Laughter ]
But these guys
are so charming and funny.
Oh, my gosh, everything.
Just a thousand laughs.
So, congratulations to everyone
over at "Gutenberg!"
and James Earl Jones Theatre.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, Anna, call me if you want
to go see a show.
Guys, today's Friday,
that's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was just wondering
if you guys wouldn't mind.
I like to write out
some thank-you notes right now.
James, can I have some
thank-you-note
writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Yeah, that's good.
Could you do it in, like,
an organ style?
Can you play, like...
♪ Vmm vmm vmm vmm ♪
♪ Vmm vmm vmm vmm,
Vmm vmm vmm vmm ♪
♪ Vmm vmm vmm vmm ♪
♪♪
Am I not hearing it?
-I can't hear it.
♪♪
[ Musical flourish plays ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
[ Ding! ]
Yeah!
That's the jam right there.
♪ Ba da boo wop a wow ♪
♪ Ba da boo bop a bow,
ba da boo bop a bow ♪
♪ Ba da boo bop a bow ♪
♪ Ba da boo bop a bow,
ba da boo bop a bow ♪
♪ Ba da boo bop a bow ♪
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
-Oh. What's that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You sat in front of her?
-Yeah, she was right there.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Those are good seats.
-Moving her head around,
trying to see...
-'Cause you're wearing
your giant hat that you wear.
-Yeah, I was
wearing my hairpiece.
Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
No, she's very lovely. I do --
I do love running into her.
But it was a good crowd.
It was super fun.
Yeah, it was great.
But, you know, I...
I just had a better view
than she did.
-Yeah. Whatever.
Yeah, right.
Not a big deal.
-We saw the same thing.
-Yeah, sure.
-Kind of.
-Yeah.
But you saw better --
Your view was about
one foot better. Yeah.
-Less.
-Oh, sure.
-Less than one foot.
But just --
Let's just say "better."
-All right.
Like that, I could --
we could touch hands.
-Right?
You could reach or you'd reach
back and touch hands.
-Yeah. I had to reach back
and strain myself.
[ Laughter ]
And normally,
if we went together...
-Right, she'd be sitting
next to you.
-Yeah.
We could hold hands here.
-Right.
But no.
-No.
-Back seat.
-I shouldn't even be
holding her hand at all.
It wasn't a scary play.
It was --
I had no business
holding her hand.
-But you were anyway?
-I think it was her hand.
I didn't look behind me.
-You just put your hand
out like this?
Somebody grabbed it?
-Yeah, someone grabbed it.
-I was nervous.
-Yeah.
I haven't seen a live play
in a long time.
-Yeah, you haven't seen one
in five months.
-I was getting scared.
I go, "What's all these lights?"
-Especially because today --
That was Friday the 13th Eve
yesterday.
-Yeah. By the time -- if I --
if the play went long,
I would have been there
on Friday the 13th.
-Yeah.
-Scary.
-It ended around 8:39.
-What?
8:39 exactly?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-8:39.
Union rules.
-Oh, really?
-Every Broadway show has to end
at 8:39.
-8:39, wow.
-Yeah.
On Thursday the 12th.
-Thursday the 12th. Yeah.
-It was good.
You should go see it.
-I will.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Save it, save it.
[ Applause ]
Ready?
[ Clears throat ]
-[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
-Thank you, autumn,
for being fall's legal name.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Like a nickname.
-Autumn Jo Smith.
♪♪
-Thank you, scarves,
for being the only clothes
that you put on with attitude.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Really?
Why not?
-Why not?
♪♪
-Thank you, step ladders.
You're not my real ladder,
but I can tell you
make my mom very happy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-"Get away from me!
You're not my real ladder!"
[ Laughter ]
-"This is my step ladder, Doug."
♪♪
Thank you, British TV shows,
for reminding me
that just because
it's in English
doesn't mean
I don't need subtitles.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Gibberish ]
-Huh?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
being offered banana bread,
for being told all
of our bananas started to rot,
so, well, here you go.
Enjoy that."
-Live it up.
-You don't have to tell me that.
-Yeah.
-"Yeah, they're all going bad,
so we made this for you."
[ Laughter ]
-They were moldy.
-[ Chuckles ]
Thank you, V.R. headsets
for being the coolest way
to look like you're wearing
a jockstrap on your head.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey! Oh!
It smells ripe.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
plastic vampire teeth,
for being Dracula's Invisalign.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Couldn't have done that joke
10 years ago.
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Thank you,
kids who carve pumpkins
with super elaborate designs,
for making me think,
"That's really impressive,"
as well as,
"Do not anger this kid."